First I'm going to make a 2-element queue,.
I'm going to set temporary variable r1 to be the return value
of enqueuing an element and set r2 to be the returned value of enqueuing
another element, r3--a third element, r4 to be the value returned by dequeuing an element,
r5 to be the returned value of dequeuing another element, and finally r6
to be the returned value of dequeuing yet another element.
Now the question that I'm asking is what are the values of these 6 variables.
Choice A is going to be 6, 7, 8, 6, 7, 8.
Choice as B is going to be True, True, True, 6, 7, None.
Choice C is going to be True, True, False, 6, 7, 8.
Choice D is going to be True, True, False, 6, 7, None.
Go ahead and write your answer here.